[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un pan de montagne qui se détache qui
s'écroule dans le lac artificiel créé
par le barrage de vaillant et c'est le
drame le plus monstrueux de l'année
l'eau du lac passe par-dessus le barrage
des millions de mètres cubes d'eau dans
une vague gigantesque se déverse à
travers la plaine détruisant la petite
ville de longarone et effaçant de la
carte 8 autres villages
[Musique]
seul le clocher de pirago émerge de la
destruction générale homme femme enfant
ont été surpris dans leur sommeil par le
cataclysme
[Musique]
il faut déblayer mais les efforts des
équipes de secours et des 2000 soldats
envoyés sur les lieux semblent
dérisoires en face d'une telle
dévastation que reste-t-il des villages
d'hier rien
il semble qu'à part quelques ruines tout
soit englouti
peu de blessés et peu de survivants 4000
morts dont la moitié à peine ont été
retrouvées et des pauvres gens tout à
coup sans famille et sans foyer ces
longs garonnes un nom qui ne désigne
plus rien qu'un drame
[Musique]
habilis l'épreuve de force n'a pas eu
lieu on avait pu la craindre quand
l'ordre avait été donné à l'Armée
nationale populaire de faire mouvement
vers les centres tenus par les rebelles
mais l'affrontement lorsqu'il s'est
produit est toujours resté Pacifique
dissident d'un côté troupes régulières
de l'eau en définitive les premiers
cédèrent la place au second après
quelques palabre qui n'exclure pas par
endroits certaines formes de
fraternisation provisoire
à Michelet les deux leaders donnèrent
l'exemple à etamed et le colonel moan où
elle Adge optèrent pour le départ sans
effusion de sang avant l'arrivée des
chars et des soldats de la NP
Michelet comme toutes les villes de
Kabylie fut ainsi occupée sans coup
férir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quant au rebelle ils ont pris avec leur
chef le chemin du maquis
[Musique]
pour nous a pu dire ben Bella l'affaire
kabyle est réglée mais il reste les
irréductibles de la montagne
[Musique]
c'est dans le Jura que ce sont déroulés
cette année les grandes manœuvres
d'automne de l'armée française manœuvre
dont le déroulement suivi par le
ministre des Armées monsieur Messmer
visait à expérimenter les armes
actuelles dans l'opposition d'un parti
rouge et d'un parti bleu épaulé cette
fois par la défense opérationnelle du
territoire le général de Gaulle venu
assister aux phases finales avis ainsi
poussé à l'horizon les champignons
fictifs qui précédaient la contrefensive
des chars à MX capables d'évoluer en
milieu partiellement radioactif
c'est manœuvres inhabituelles se sont
achevés de la manière la plus classique
à Besançon le chef de l'État a présidé
le défilé auquel prenait pas hélicoptère
avion de transport chasseur à réaction
ainsi que plusieurs centaines de blindés
qui suivaient les troupes à pied
[Musique]
Édith Piaf est morte
notre reporter l'avait surprise il y a
peu de temps Alain de ces moments où
renaissante après une crise de la
maladie qui vient cette fois de
l'emporter et qui la terrassa plusieurs
fois déjà elle faisait de nouveau projet
et souriait une nouvelle fois à la vie
dans trois semaines puisque chanter
c'est ma vie je ne peux pas m'empêcher
de chanter et je le chanterai très vite
pour vous j'ai payé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la maladie a été la plus forte et tous
les grands noms de la chanson française
d'Yves Montand à Tino Rossi et à Gilbert
Bécaud sont venus apporter leur hommage
à cette voie inoubliable qui restera
comme un écho de notre époque et c'est
pourquoi la foule de Paris pendant des
heures à défilé devant son cercueil
comme devant une amie très bonne et très
aimée
quelques heures après dans son village
de Milly-la-Forêt s'éteignait toucher au
cœur peut-être par la mort d'Édith Piaf
celui qui fut l'infanterie de la
littérature d'une époque et l'esprit le
plus brillant d'une génération Jean
Cocteau
celui à qui a 22 ans yaguilé avec dit
étonne-moi et qui pendant 50 ans étonna
le monde poème ou des saintes théâtre ou
cinéma il toucha à tout touche à tout de
génie passant de l'illustration de ses
livres à la décoration d'une chapelle
passant des mariés de la Tour Eiffel aux
enfants terribles et de l'éternel retour
au sein d'un poète à l'avant-garde des
lettres il n'en fut pas moins l'élu de
la tradition lorsqu'il entra à
l'Académie française il ne rapportait
que huit ans la bivert mais il possédait
déjà son immortalité le Tout-Paris des
Arts et des Lettres le cinéma avec René
Clair la scène avec Brialy et Jean
Marais sont venus saluer la silhouette
frêle usée par la maladie qui avait
animé l'esprit le plus étincelant
il reste son œuvre et c'est une partie
de cette œuvre aux mille facettes qui
survivra tout près de sa maison à
Saint-Blaise des simples dans cette
chapelle ou à l'ombre des formes qu'il a
créé reposera le poète Jean Cocteau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
commencez voici quelques semaines
l'offensive contre la hausse des prix
est aujourd'hui engagée sur tous les
fronts dans 100000 points de vente on
peut suivre le jeu des basses consenties
par les organisations professionnelles
ou organisées grâce à l'effort des
magasins pilotes
si le secteur de la viande demeure le
point névralgique de la campagne il
semble que sur les autres produits la
décision penche du bon côté pour le
savoir notre reporter a interrogé au
hasard quelques-uns de ces gens qui sont
comme la plupart d'entre nous du côté du
panier de la ménagère qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cette opération stabilité des
prix 100000 points de vente et bien
monsieur j'ai constaté que sur certains
articles dans certains magasins parce
qu'il y a certainement eu un effort de
baisse je trouve que ici c'est encore
ils ont gardé leurs prix mais les
bouchers par exemple c'est affreux mais
je pense que je sais très bien je pense
que ça va continuer on s'aperçoit quand
même qu'il y a un tantinet de base quand
même tout à fait très très sensible
enfin parce que le gouvernement a raison
de t'appliquer ces méthodes mais et
quelle stabilité des prix jusqu'à
présent je me suis pas encore vraiment
rendu compte si c'est il faut faire une
économie sur un marché de 5 ou 10 francs
pour moi c'est encore rien c'est très
bien monsieur je trouve ça très bien ça
diminue un peu le budget vous savez pour
la question des gens qui sont
difficile je trouve que c'est très bien
vous avez constaté une baisse
intéressante sur certains produits mais
oui monsieur parfaitement du Régence
sera encore à l'instant et bien mettons
sur les pâtes sur l'huile la semaine
dernière c'était le chocolat cette
semaine cette soirée les gâteaux puis
après il y a la salade tout ça ça se
suit bien on se trouve que il faut faire
un effort de ce côté-là et continuer les
pommes actuellement vous voyez quand
même une stabilité dans les prix et les
panneaux
je crois qu'elle est forcer mais
insister sur bifteck la campagne de
stabilisation encore à son début doit
créer un équilibre stable entre le
panier et le porte-monnaie
[Musique]
les Parisiens attendaient un miracle de
Ray sugar Robinson culotte blanche le
plus grand boxeur de la pragaire ils
avaient publié que raichuger a 43 ans
Robinson avocat chez son âge parqueterie
il ne peut plus faire illusion sur un
rythme
il a pourtant toujours grande allure il
est très bel athlète mais cela ne suffit
pas pour vaincre sans discussion un
adversaire
on reste Vanucci qui lui est opposé fait
mieux que de se défendre et pourtant
Vanucci n'est pas un superman
15 cas le combat va jusqu'à la limite
sans donner cependant le grand frisson
au spectateur
[Applaudissements]
finalement victoire au point pour
Robinson une victoire un peu tirée par
les cheveux qui n'a convaincu personne
[Musique]